it's that time again to talk to you
about the latest games in new releases
and this week we have a demonic game
that has a pretty well timed release
right about after you've either finished
or rage quit dark souls 2 bound by flame
choose between increasing your power
with evil or continuing on your own to
develop your own heroic talents several
companions will join you on your quest
but will you choose romance friendship
or nemesis keep your friends close and
your enemies closer may nine baseball
fans this week get fancy new beard
effects with MLB the show on PlayStation
4 over 200 new fielding animations like
helmets flying off sliding runners get
more environments and player detail and
more fluid gameplay Sammy Sosa is gonna
get really confused now he is
so can the high polygon count may six
also this week executioner's are wanted
as killer is dead nightmare edition
makes its way to PC replay your role of
mondo as you kill dangerous criminals
and assassins from around the world but
this version has nightmare mode where
enemies can only be defeated using 13
attacks adrenaline burst dodge burst and
headshots all while maintaining your
smooth looks and one-liners open your
eyes it's time to time the nightmare
begins April night in the weirder games
this week you get the live action super
sleuthing Tesla effect the tex murphy
adventure players navigate 3d
environments in first-person search for
clues as well as solve logic puzzles and
a branching conversation system allows
you to interrogate characters oh that's
right buddy you show that Turner's boss
start narrating your own path may 7th
and finally we enter a world of paper
and stickers would stick it to the man
making its way to ps4 as we you may six
learn what it's like to have a giant
pink spaghetti arms sticking out of your
brain that lets you read people's minds
and fold and tear the world itself not
too weird or anything also Vita owners
this week get some classics including
Borderlands 2 and God of War may six for
further details visit gamespot's new
releases page release dates are based on
retailer listings and are subject to
change see you next week
eight miles